It's been about three months since this, what
I call my $829 10 minute doctor's visit.
I told the initial part of the story before
and I've been getting emails from people,
including podiatrists saying, David, what
ended up happening with this?
So here's the backstory.
In early June, I went to see a podiatrist
because I was having some foot and a knee
pain.
And uh, my regular doctor suggested I go,
I did all the right things.
I called my insurance.
I said, is podiatry covered?
They said, yes, it is.
I said, do I need a referral?
They said, no, you don't do I need prior?
Do I need pre-authorization?
They said, no, you don't just book it and
go, you'll pay your $40 copay or whatever
it is for specialist and you're going to be
good to go.
And I went and uh, the doctor said, hey, uh,
okay.
I think that the problem you're having is
that because of, uh, your flat arches, it's
throwing your entire ankles and knees out
of alignment.
You should get some or thought kind of custom
orthotic insoles, which of course they didn't
make their, nor are they covered by insurance.
The orthotics are 350 or 375 bucks.
Here's a prescription, but a boom, better
bang, you're outta here.
Okay, I pay my copay.
And then a few weeks later I get a bill, a
bill saying your visit with the specialist,
which was 10 minutes, maybe it was 10 minutes,
it was 10 minutes with me spending three minutes
sitting there while of the podiatrist types
up notes.
Right?
That was a 460 or so dollar visit.
You've paid your $40 copay, it's not covered.
So you owe the other $420 or so.
And I called the insurance and I want to tell
a shorter version of this since I've already
told this.
I called my insurance and they say, well,
podiatry is covered and you don't need a referral
and you don't need prior authorization, but
your diagnosis was past planning or as we
would say in English flat feet.
And that is not a diagnosis that is covered
to which I said, wait a second, how I'm not
a doctor.
Do you agree?
I'm not a doctor?
Yes, yes, we agree you're not a doctor.
Um, how would I know whether to expect a diagnosis
which would not be covered?
It doesn't really seem to make any sense.
So in the end, what was potentially going
to happen is I was going to owe for this 10
minute visit, which results in me getting
some orthotics, um, 350 or three 75 for the
orthotics and four 40 or so, whatever.
For the a specialist visit, it was going to
be roughly $830.
Now I've got a bunch of emails from podiatrist
saying, David, I, I deal with this with patients.
And it's crazy that on the basis of a diagnosis
code, you would either be covered or not covered,
but here are a bunch of other codes that,
this is not insurance fraud, but these are
just other ways that you can report that someone
came in with a, a, a pain related to a foot
condition.
And here's how I would often code it.
So I played the game.
Now at a certain point, I mean, listen, the
truth is if this ends up costing me eight
29, I'm fortunate enough to be in a situation
where it's not going to bankrupt me and I'm
putting a lot of time into this, but I do
want to see it through just to see like how
long will it take to ultimately navigate this
and what will be the result.
So I got in touch with the, uh, specialist.
They put me in touch with some billing person
who of course, should they even exist in a
system that makes sense.
Is that even a position that we should have
inflating the bureaucratic cost of these visits?
I would say no.
They said we're going to resubmit it.
I'm going to talk to the doctor when the doctor,
if the doctor agrees to resubmit it in a different
way, we will do that.
Call us in a month.
I called in a month and was told that that
billing person had left and not on good terms,
therefore no one there knows what it is that
they were working on.
So we again started from scratch and I am
here to report to you today that there has
been no progress whatsoever.
My, uh, the, the specialist has said, we're
not going to start charging you late fees.
We understand that we're in the process of
trying to work this out so you're not going
to owe us late fees.
But it has finally been resubmitted to my
insurance with some other diagnostic codes.
Uh, and I'm waiting to hear back and it could
be several more weeks before they either accept
or deny the claim, the consider all of the
people and for what was seven minutes of clinical
time and three minutes of notetaking time.
Consider not only what I might end up paying,
but the amount of hours that I've put into
this.
Again, partially for you to have stuff to
talk about on the show because of the curiosity
of the entire thing, but this has been hours
of my time.
Add up all of the hours of everybody else
who's been involved.
There's people at my insurance company that
have to process this claim two times multiple
people at the specialist's office, including
the podiatrist himself working on resubmitting
this, I'm calling.
It's insane the system that we have and in
the end, I'm not really any closer to avoiding
an $829 10 minute doctor's visit than I was
when this all started.
Now if you're going to email me and say, David,
in my country, a custom orthotic insoles are
only a hundred bucks.
I already heard from two dozen of you.
I understand that.
I, I trust me, I get that even the price of
$350 is a crazy price and people from Canada
and the UK saying, I just got custom ones
for 80 bucks, a hundred bucks and the insurance
even covers it.
In some cases they don't even depress me further
with those stories.
I get that that piece is going on, but that's
the latest and I will certainly keep you abreast
of any developments there.